two days ago this was a bustling
community now it's a ghost town one of
the closest places to to our volcano
it's right in the path of the eruption
ash has fallen like snow stripping the
color from the world up the road
Annie's getting ready to leave she and
her six children were trapped in the
house by falling ash at the weekend if
they don't go now she fears they may not
escape a bigger eruption I'm really
afraid and I'm in a hat because
everything then I ate great you know how
honking bah humbug society Lucas I seen
that better honey well in Tulum the
volcano has knocked out the electricity
in the water the military will be here
soon to tell them to leave animals have
to be left behind despite the danger and
his brother Rafi is determined to stay
to watch over their homes so you'll only
leave when you're forced to go yes ma'am
I'm on it
from a distance this volcano may look
karma than it has done in days but on a
surface is a very different picture new
cracks have opened up there are new
fissures we're being told that lava is
being shot hundreds of meters into the
air and you can still see the ash cloud
there and authorities say this is still
extremely dangerous and could get worse
in days if not hours this is the most
explosive the volcano's been in more
than 40 years visiting affected areas
today president de Ternay
admitted there was no clear end in sight
this crisis seems to be a continuing one
whether it will grow into a big
explosion or it will simmer down we have
yet to see what develops in the days to
come but all of a qyz like Annie can do
now is wait nature will decide if her
family and thousands of others have
homes to return to Siobhan Robbins Sky
News tag I tithe the Philippines